revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 me acompaña en el estudio rosa
pérez más de euros
bienvenida a feliz mañana ya de
miércoles vamos a repasar entonces las
portadas de rosa teniendo en cuenta lo
que ocurrió ayer en el estado de texas
en eeuu esta nueva matanza buenos días
raúl exactamente hemos hecho una pequeña
selección de esta matanza que a pesar de
que las autoridades todavía no han
encontrado o al menos no han expresado
la motivación a no de esta masacre es
imposible de desligar temporalmente con
la masacre racista en ese caso que
ocurrió en buffalo hace apenas diez días
pero bueno vamos a la huston chronicle
este medio del estado de texas que dice
la peor pesadilla y es que aquí vemos
imágenes todavía como veremos en las
distintas portadas de familiares que
todavía no sabían si sus hijos estaban
entre los asesinados no en esta masacre
bien y este medio destaca el asesinato
de al menos 19 menores y dos profesores
marca el tiroteo más en una escuela en
texas porque lamentablemente es
importante especificar esto porque ha
habido tiroteos más mortíferos tanto en
escuelas afuera del estado de texas como
en el propio estado de texas en pues
infraestructuras en lugares que no eran
escuelas y en ese sentido también a los
señalar wall street journal que dice el
ataque es el más mortal en una escuela
desde el de sandy hook en 2012 como
comentabas en el informativo en
connecticut donde pues 28 personas
perdieron la vida incluido el atacante
así ha sucedido también de hecho en
balde en texas ayer cuando la policía no
mató finalmente al atacante que ha sido
identificado por las autoridades como
salvador ramos de 18 años ex estudiante
de esta misma escuela donde ha
perpetrado la matanza y que según nos
cuentan los distintos periódicos
adquirió las armas con las que pues
ejecutado este ataque pues al cumplir
los 18 años como decíamos el fbi
desconoce de momento la motivación los
hechos y también el wall street journal
en el wall street journal lo relaciona
con la matanza de parkland de florida
que también pues recordemos en 2018 que
dejó 17 muertos vamos al 'washington
post' que dice es el tiroteo masivo pues
es el último de una avalancha de
violencia que asola la nación y
precisamente la nación de argentina dice
otra masacre en eeuu el país que ya se
acostumbró al horror no pues un titular
que expresa bastante lo que muchos creen
no es unas noticias que lamentablemente
son bastante recurrentes finalmente la
vanguardia vemos que también tiene en
portada este medio español pues una
imagen no de texas y en este caso la
relaciona también como lo que decíamos
esta masacre de búfalo que en el caso en
el que el autor pues se declaró a sí
mismo como fascista y mató a 10 personas
trozo vamos a seguir con el new york
times dice cómo reducir los tiroteos es
un artículo de opinión
exactamente el artículo empieza
américa recordemos ellos lo llaman así
pero se refieren a eeuu ha sido sacudido
una vez más por tiroteos masivos y
destacar que este texto fue escrito en
2017 raúl hace cinco años y el 'new york
times' lo vuelve a publicar porque como
pues bien dice el texto y como bien se
comenta pues eeuu no han logrado digamos
resolver el caso de los tiroteos masivos
ya son más de 200 tiroteos masivos en
este 2022 y se entiende por tiroteos
masivos los que pues digamos suponen la
muerte a más de cuatro personas bien en
lo que propone el autor de este artículo
es enfocar el tema de los tiroteos no
como una cuestión de regulación de armas
dice que esto ya se intenta hacer desde
hace décadas y no funciona sino como una
cuestión de salud pública así como se
hace con la seguridad vial no y que la
cuestión es intentar pues reforzar un
poco las regulaciones y los controles
finalmente antes de permitir que la
gente adquiera armas como sobre todo
de repasar los antecedentes de los
compradores ya que cerca del 20% de las
armas que se venden a nivel privado pues
no tienen en cuenta los antecedentes
pues como decíamos de los compradores y
también para señalar cifras que ya
comentamos hay a raíz de la matanza de
búfalo en eeuu se encuentran la mitad de
las armas que tienen los ciudadanos a
nivel privado en el mundo hay 393
millones de armas en circulación en
manos privadas para 328 millones de
personas según el estudio small arms
survey rosa otro tema que hemos traído
aquí es el del asesinato de chilina
bucle en otros medios se suman a
realizar investigaciones independientes
sobre estos hechos rosa exactamente es
el caso de las tienen y de ape que
realizan investigaciones muy parecidas
la que comentamos aquí del medio de
investigación del incap no en este caso
ambos en medios de comunicación
estadounidenses a lo que realizan es un
análisis de la geolocalización un
análisis de las imágenes y de los audios
de los distintos vídeos que circularon
en en el momento de los hechos del
asesinato de chirilagua clay la
periodista recordemos de al yazira bien
llegan un poco a la misma conclusión a
que llegó del inca ttc y es que red de
hecho en la posición de las fuerzas
israelís en el momento del asesinato de
chilina buckler pues coincide con el
lugar desde el cual fue disparada la
bala que mató a la periodista y que
entre la posición del convoy israelí y
la posición donde cayó la periodista no
se encontraban combatientes palestinos
no y de hecho ambos medios pues
concluyen que todas las evidencias van
enfocadas en digamos confirmar la
versión de los testigos y es que el
ataque fue dirigido contra los
periodistas rosa gracias por toda la
información de esta revista de prensa
pasamos a saludar en nuestro primer
invitado el día
[Música]